Russian airline pilots averted a
disaster this morning outside Moscow
they landed their jet in a cornfield
after a bird strike when it took off
incredibly no one was killed
passengers were seen near the field
after the crash landing Holly Williams
is tracking this story from London Holly
the video is incredibly scary that's
right good morning well the passengers
on board the Airbus 321 must have seen
their lives flash before their eyes the
video of the plane heading towards the
ground is pretty distressing to watch
you can hear the engines laboring
apparently losing power and then screams
from the passengers as they hit the
ground the planes landing gear was
reportedly still up so no wheels on the
ground but miraculously the pilot
managed to land in a cornfield just
outside Moscow Airport and all 226
passengers and 7 crew members survived
23 people have been hospitalized one
reportedly with serious injuries the
problems started when the plane collided
with a flock of gulls according to the
Russian Air Agency apparently some of
the birds were sucked into its engines
causing both of them to fail now the
pilot who presumably will now become
something of a Sully Sullenberger
character in Russia is already being
lauded as a hero as well as handsome by
one very grateful passenger his name is
Demi Yusupov and he apparently graduated
from aviation school with honors Gail
you never go wrong when you're compared
to Sully Sullenberger and handsome never
hurts either
thank you very much Holly